merci Corine marassigin d'avoir été avec
nous et de nous accompagner pendant
cette première demi-heure vous êtes élu
de la scène saint-en membre du groupe
socialiste vous faites partie des 14
parlementaires qui vont siéger lundi
dans la commission mixte paritaire pour
tenter donc de trouver un accord sur le
projet de loi immigration on va revenir
sur cette CMP dans quelques secondes
mais d'abord on le voit les négociations
elles se font entre majorité sénatoriale
et majorité présidentielle est-ce que la
gauche ne sa pas mise toute seule à
l'écart en en votant cette motion de
rejet
la gauche est tenue à l'écart de toutes
les discussions sur ce projet de loi
depuis le début c'est ça la réalité
c'est-à-dire que le texte depuis le
début Gérald hermanin choisit de le
négocier avec la droite qui elle-même
s'inspire de l'extrême droite il y a
jamais eu de discussion avec nous que ce
soit au Sénat ou à l'Assemblée nationale
puisqu'il y a quand même eu une semaine
de débat en commission pourtant c'est un
texte du en même temps on l' assez
reproché à Gérald armanin pour qu'il y
ait des mesures de gauche justement pour
que la gauche accepte aussi une partie
de ce texte la seule chose qui est en
même temps dans ce texte c'est son titre
voilà mais sinon il y a rien d'autre en
même temps dans le texte surtout pas ce
qu'il en reste aujourd'hui mais même au
départ c'était un texte déjà très
déséquilibré mais est-ce que vous n'avez
pas fait une erreur est-ce qu'il aurait
pas mieux valu discuter de ce texte à
l'Assemblée nationale et faire valoir
vos arguments et tenter de peser sur
l'issue finale du texte non c'est pas la
faute de la gauche ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui la gauche elle a joué son
rôle à l'Assemblée c'est normal de
pouvoir utiliser toutes les procédures
législatives quand on est dans
l'opposition les motions de rejet en
font partie évidemment il en avait une
qui avait été déposée aussi au Sénat
évidemment au Sénat on savait bien qu'il
avait aucune chance de passer
mais la gauche elle s'oppose au texte il
y a aucune version de ce texte qui
pourrait nous satisfaire elle a nous
avons en tant que socialistes les
députés socialistes ont voté un texte de
motion de rejet de gauche déposé par les
écologistes le problème c'est le
problème de
la la majorité relative macronist qui
n'a pas fait le plein de ses voix et qui
s'est fait avoir par la droite alors
qu'elle avait déjà tout cédé à la droite
donc il faut pas porter les responsab
enfin faire porter le chapeau à
simplement des parlementaires qui jouent
leur rôle leur rôle d'opposant et quand
vous entendez le gouvernement qui vous
dit que vous êtes allié avec le
rassemblement national qu'est-ce que
vous dites oui enfin ça c'est ça c'est
vraiment ridicule c'est c'est pas là on
a voter je rappelle un texte
écologiste c'est pas la gauche qui a mis
début tout un rassemblement dans luurne
pour élire des vice-présidents
rassemblement national à l'Assemblée
nationale et c'est pas non plus la
gauche qui établit des projets de loi
dont on sait très bien qu'il passe ou au
493 ou très souvent avec l'appui
délibéré du rassemblement national
est-ce que du coup vous n'avez pas fait
vous aussi le jeu de la droite puisque
maintenant les négociations vont se
faire on va en parler sur un texte sur
le texte du Sénat et s'il y a accord le
texte sera forcément plus dur que celui
de la commission des lois à l'Assemblée
alors déjà il faut sortir d'un mythe qui
serait que que le texte aurait été
largement détricoté en commission des
lois à l'Assemblée nationale en réalité
il y a quelques petites améliorations
c'est vrai mais pour l'essentiel ce qui
a été retiré ce sont des choses qui de
toute façon auraient été censuré
seraient censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel donc il faut aussi
regarder les choses comme elles sont et
puis la réalité c'est que la CMP aurait
été la même la composition de la CMP
aurait été la même le problème de
trouver un accord entre le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale à la fin texte
mais il aurait eu de Tex un texte de
l'Assemblée un texte du Sénat là il en
aun sén je sais bien qu'il y a un texte
qui a un peu plus de légitimité parce
qu'il a été voté au Sénat mais en
réalité le le le les parlementaires ont
les moyens de faire ou de défaire tout
ce qu'ils veulent dans une CMP et donc
elle aurait été à peu près la même
qu'elle a eu lieu ce lundi ou au mois de
janvier et justement on va en parler de
cette CMP et du fond de ce texte Quentin
calm va nous rejoindre puisque chacun
fixe ses lignes rouges alors quels sont
les points d'accord quels sont les
points désaccord on voit ça avec lui
[Musique]
bonjour Quentin bonjour orien bonjour
corineigin et Quentin on le disait le
gouvernement et la droite multiplie donc
les rendez-vous en vue de la réunion de
lundi la fam la fameuse commission mixte
paritaire voilà tic tac il ne reste plus
que 3 jours avant cette réunion de la
CMP la commission mixte paritaire on le
rappelle on va revoir la composition
lundi à 17h 14 parlementaires sont
réunis à H clos 7 députés SEP sénateurs
dont vous madame Nara CIN l'exécutif on
l'a compris essaie de sceller un accord
sur ce projet de immigration avec les
républicains en amont de la réunion
ainsi depuis le début de la semaine le
gouvernement multiplie les initiatives
s'implique directement dans le dialogue
parlementaire les chefs de fil de la
droite et du centre ont été ainsi reçus
à M Tigon deux fois même pour lesalr on
voyait dans le sujet de d'Adrien pin et
on voyait les images à l'antenne il y a
quelques instants parmi les points au
cœur des négociations il y a l'aide
médical d'État la question des
régularisations des travailleurs dans
les métiers en tension les mesures qui
concernent le code de la nationalité ou
encore le versement et la fin du
versement d'allocation pour les
étrangers avant un certain délai à
propos de l'Ame l'aide médicale d'État
un compromis semble se dessiner avec le
retrait de cette mesure du projet de loi
immigration et un nouveau projet de loi
de la part du gouvernement examiné début
2023 écoutez la rapporteur LR Muriel
Jourda pour moi c'est qu'on qu'on arrive
à avoir un texte que ça soit là ou
ailleurs d'ailleurs mais un texte dans
lequel on remett en cause l'aide
médicale d'État telle qu'elle existe
alors ce qui a un peu changé la donne
c'est vrai c'est le rapport stéphanini
qui n'invalide pas d'ailleurs les propos
qu'on a pu tenir en séance qui consista
à dire que effectivement c'est un
attrait parmi d'autres l'aide médicale
d'État et c'est un attrait surtout pour
se maintenir en situation de
clandestinité sur le territoire puisque
on se rend compte que être clandestin
permet d'être mieux pris en charge par
la par pour des soins de sécurité
sociale que lorsqu'on est régulier ou
lorsqu'on est français attention Orian
leslr qui conditionne un accord sur
cette partie du texte sur l'ame avec un
engagement formel un engagement formel
de la part de l'exécutif on verra si cet
engagement formel est bien pris de la
part de l'exécutif dans les prochains
jours les rendez-vous en tout cas
devraient continuer jusqu'à la Réunion
fatidique de lundi avec même un dernier
rendez-vous prévu dimanche soir entre
les LR et l'exécutif à matigon alors
Corine narassin on le dit ça négocie dur
entre l'air et le gouvernement avant
même la réunion de lundi de la CMP
l'accord pourrait donc intervenir en
dehors de cette CMP que ça vous évoque
en fait elle sert pas franchement à
grand-chose cette réunion de lundi si
tout est Cellé avant malheureusement on
voilà encore le problème de ce
gouvernement avec le principe de la
séparation des pouvoirs ils ont quand
même l'habitude de s'asseoir sur le
Parlement là il le démontre encore parce
que normalement une CMP ça se passe
pendant la CMP entre les parlementaires
alors il y a toujours des discussions un
peu en amant mais normalement ça devrait
être des discussions entre parl c'est
pas à la prière ça n pas oui absolument
ça n'est pas au gouvernement de négocier
en plus en plein jour mais s'il l'avait
fait dans les couloirs ça aurait été ça
aurait été la même chose ça n'est pas au
gouvernement de négocier ce qui revient
au parlementairirees les parlementaires
LR on vient de le dire dans la chronique
et Renaissance qui pourrait trouver un
accord sur le fait de sortir l'aide
médicale d'État du texte pour un texte
ad hoc qu'est-ce que vous en pensez je
pense que c'est une vaste fumisterie
mais c'est un très beau coup joué par LR
qui fait de l'extorsion ça marche
visiblement parils sont prêts ils sont
prêts à céder au gouvernement parce que
on sait déjà et et même le gouvernement
en plus l'avait déjà indiqué que la
suppression de la me dans ce texte est
un cavalier législatif qui serait donc
retqu par cons censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel et donc LR est en train
de dire qu'ils sont d'accord pour
reculer sur un sujet que de toute façon
ils n'obtiendront pas à la fin donc pour
lâcher quelque chose que de toute façon
ils n pas en échange ils vont obtenir un
engagement du gouvernement sur une
réforme de laame que par ailleurs le
gouvernement a déjà dit qu'elle ferait
puisque le rapport evvin stéphanini
c'est pour engager une réforme de la me
donc tout ça c'est une vaste blague
c'est comme maintenant il négocie sur la
la le il demande il y avait cette lettre
là pour demander une réforme de la
Constitution alors que les LR ont déjà
échoué puisqu'ils ont déjà retiré leur
leur leur proposition de loi
constitutionnelle et à l'Assemblée et
Sénat par qu' n'arrivait pas à la faire
passer don maintenant ils essaient de
l'extorquer d'une autre manière donc
c'est tout ça oui mais elle devra de
toute façon passer par le Parlement donc
quand bien même Emmanuel Macron dit oui
oui sûr si c'est un engagement du
gouvernement évidemment ça n'est pas la
même chose que une une proposition de
loi d'un groupe qui n'a pas la majorité
mais il faudra quand même les 3/5e oui
bien sûr bien sûr mais enfin là on on
voit bien que c'est du marchandage
politique de bas étage et où on essaie
d'obtenir des choses qui n'ont rien à
voir avec le texte et qui de chç là bien
sûr c'est euh c'est assez terrible mais
je je je pense que de toute façon
c'était attendu ça aurait eu lieu de
toute manière
euh aussi au mois de janvier si on avait
eu un un texte d'abord débattu à
l'Assemblée et que cette CMP aurait lieu
au mois de janvier parce que on sait que
c'est ce que prépare les LR depuis le
début on peut continuer avec les autres
articles du texte qu'on a évoqué l'aide
médicale d'État mais il y a d'autres
points qui sont au cœur des négociations
par exemple le fameux article après qui
s'est appelé 4 bis sur la régularisation
de travailleurs sans papier dans
certains secteurs en tension c'est donc
la version a priori du Sénat qui tient
l'accorde avec une régularisation au cas
par cas par les préfets est-ce que vous
regrettez que le gouvernement pour le
coup dise banco
OLR c'éit un des points du texte que
vous pouz soutenir dans l'article 3
initial oui enfin c'était c'était
l'article 3 initial était insuffisant
mais enfin all est dans la bonne
direction là effectivement il y avait
une toute petite amélioration en
commission des lois qui restait qui
gardait quand même le pouvoir
discrétionnaire du préfet pas voilà à
l'Assemblée nationale qui n'en faisait
pas un droit opposable comme ça devait
être le cas dans la version initiale du
texte ils ont simplement enlevé le fait
que les employeurs ont leur mot à dire
dans le processus mais ça je pense que
de toute façon ça reste quelque chose
qui est un sujet de la CMP qui de toute
façon aurait été un sujet de la CMP
puisque c'est une demande d'une partie
du groupe renaiss à l'Assemblée
nationale dont le gouvernement a besoin
pour faire passer le texte à l'Assemblée
nationale le le texte issu de la CMP
devrait être voté et par le Sénat et par
l'Assemblée nationale donc cette
question de réconciliation voilà donc
cette question de réconciliation si si
la CMP aboutit effectivement cette
question de réconciliation des majorités
sénatoriales et Assemblée nationale sur
ce pointl de toute façon il il est il
est entier depuis le début on le sait
oui continue on continue il y a d'autres
articles ut parler de cette
conditionnalité avant le versement des
allocations sociales là aussi il y a un
bras de fer les LR veulent une une
présence depuis plusieurs années sur le
territoire avant que les étrangers
puissent toucher ces aides sociales
actuellement c'est un délai de de 6 mois
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ça serait
vraiment scandaleux si le gouvernement
acceptait de plier sur ce sujet-là
pourquoi euh parce que là c'est vraiment
une rupture d'égalité totale et c'est
vraiment laisser libre cours à la
xénophobie dans ce pays de dire qu'en
fait fait tous les étrangers qui sont
sur ce territoire légalement qui payent
des impôts qui travaillent n'ont droit à
rien avant 5 ans sur ce territoire ça
n'est pas possible de de de de lancer
comme ça un climat de de d'alimenter un
climat général de suspicion contre les
étrangers et par ailleurs je crois que
cette cette disposition là c'est une
profonde rupture d'égalité dans notre
pays et que c'est une vraie question à
poser aussi au Conseil constitutionnel
et je crois que ça a même été souligné
par la la Défenseur des droits et l'air
qui tienent à cette mesure ils nous
l'ont redit hier une dernière question
les élus Renaissance qui eux mettent une
autre ligne rouge ils veulent
l'interdiction du placement en centre de
rétention administratif qu'on appelle
les cras pour les mineurs ça c'est un
point que vous soutenez euh oui mais ça
c'était ça pour le coup c'est déjà c'est
l'application du droit de des
recommandations du droit européen et
puis et puis en fait ça ça n'avait même
pas été touché
par le le le Sénat c'était dans le texte
depuis le début et ça a été voté en
sortant du Sénat donc je sais même pas
pourquoi pourquoi oui Maillard on parle
ou on fait une ligne rouge pour vous
c'était évident bon on voit il y a
beaucoup de lign rouge vous pensez qu'il
y aura un accord au final euh je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas parce que à vrai dire
ça dépend pas vraiment de nous
évidemment nous de notre côté ce qu'on
souhaite c'est que cette CMP n'aboutisse
pas puisqueemmanuel Macron a déjà a déjà
dit que si n'aboutit pas et le texte
serait retiré ce qui est quand même pour
nous la meilleure
solution mais je voilà je pense que ça
dépend à la que c'est àabouti il ne soit
pas voté à l'assemblée oui oui le mieux
ça serait que ça serait qu'on s'arrête d
lundi soir on arrête ça dès lundi
soir c'est c'est c'est je crois on va
voir si les LR onont décider d'aller
jusqu'au bout de leur la logique qu'ils
ont commencé à l'Assemblée en votant la
motion de Roget et donc d'aller au bout
de mettre Gérald D'man en difficulté et
ou si le gouvernement est prêt à céder
cûte que cûte pour afficher
une forme de de victoire sur ce texte
tout en cédant totalement à la droite et
à l'extrême droite merci Contin tout à à
tout à l'heure oui de oui de ce courrier
des élus LR adressés au président de la
République pour ouvrir le chantier de la
révision constitutionnelle sur ce sujet
de l'immigration on en parle dans le
club on va parler de la gauche puisque
on l'a vu dans votre combat contre cette
loi immigration il y a eu notamment ce
meeting de la gauche pour s'opposer avec
des socialistes des écologistes F des
communistes et la France insoumise mais
sans la frange Jean-Luc Mélenchon est-ce
que c'est ça les contours de la nouvelle
union de la gauche
aujourd'hui on a aussi invité on avait
aussi invité des personnes qui étaient
plus proche de Jean-Lou Mélenchon
notamment le député de la
circonscription Eric coqurel et puis et
puis le le
corrapporteur de du groupe France
insoumise à l'Assemblée nationale il se
trouve que il nétait pas disponible il
ne pouvait pas venir donc il y avait pas
de sur ce sujet-là nous sommes nous
sommes tous d'accord sur le sujet de la
contre ce projet de loi nous som et plus
largement est-ce que on sait qu'il y a
un moratoire il va durer jusqu'à quand
d'ailleurs ce moratoire bien sûr on sait
qu'il y a des difficultés aujourd'hui
que la nubesse telle qu'elle a existé ne
fonctionne plus et que elle doit être
largement redébatue alors je je crois
pas peut-être pas dans ses contours
politiques largement mais plutôt sur sa
question de la question de son
fonctionnement interne et c'est là
uniquement son fonctionnement c'estàd
vous pouvez réintégrer Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et ses proches et ceux qui
sont je crois que il y a des points de
de fond sur lesquels il faudra avoir des
discussions jusqu'au bout avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et ses proches puisque s'il y
a eu rupture c'est parce qu'il y avait
quand même des des désaccords de fond
important mais le sujet principal c'est
quand même la question de justement de
respecter les uns et les autres qu'on
puisse aussi admettre que parfois on
peut avoir des d d'accords il y a eu
beaucoup de de
gouvernements de de coalition à à gauche
où on éétait pas tous d'accord y compris
sur les question internation sont
dépables ces divergen il est pas allé
trop loin Jean-Luc Mélenchon je pense
que sur certain points il est allé très
très loin oui mais je je crois qu'il
faut pas résumer déjà tous ceux qui ont
voté pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et donc la question c'est plus
plus globalement comment est-ce que on
trouve une dynamique on défin des des
contours des combats communs qui peuvent
nous permettre de préparer la suite et
et de se donner les moyens à la gauche
et aux écologistes d'être au deuxième
tour de l'élection présidentielle la
question auss c'est est-ce que vous pvez
est-ce que vous pouvez vraiment vous
passer de jeanluc enchon mais je crois
que personne n'est jamais indispensable
et et en particulier quand on est la
France insoumise et qu'on demande la fin
de la 5e République on devrait arrêter
de personnifier autant les choses une
candidature commune de la gauche pour la
présidentielle de 2027 se prépare malgré
les listes séparées aux européennes 2024
c'est ce que dit marine Tondelier est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire plus euh
alors il y a pas de de négociation ou de
discussion très concrète aujourd'hui sur
ce sujet-là simplement je je crois que
Marie Tondelier a simplement rappelé ce
qu'elle dit depuis le départ depuis
qu'elle a pris la tête des écologistes
qui est que y compris à travers ces
campagnes européennes qu'on va mener les
uns à côté des autres et pas sur une
liste unique on doit continuer à
travailler ensemble parce que pour 2027
on doit se donner les moyens d'être au
deuxième tour et de gagner et donc ça
veut dire préparer une candidature
unique ou pour les européennes Daniel
conbendit qui a été un temps proche de
d'Emmanuel Macron et qui maintenant on
revient un peu dit qu'il faudrait une
alliance entre socialiste écologiste et
Parti radical de gauche est-ce que vous
vous êtes favorable
euh je je crois que sur le la la
question de l'élargissement bien sûr il
faudra s'élargir pour faire une majorité
aujourd'hui le socle de la gauche n'est
pas majoritaire d'abord mais d'abord il
faut commencer par consolider ce qui se
parlent déjà entre eux ceux qui sont
d'accord sur l'essentiel déjà et ensuite
une fois qu'on a consolidé on élargit
euh mais on commence pas essayer de
chercher les les les les bords avant
d'avoir un cœur qui est bien solide
voilà mais est-ce que là d'avoir autant
de listes à gauche pour les européennes
c'est bien raisonnable alors les
européennes c'est un c'est un mode de
scrutin différent c'est la
proportionnelle à un tour et et par
ailleurs il est possible si nous faisons
chacun de bonnes campagnes de finir avec
plus de députés européens de gauche que
si nous étions tous sur la même liste
est-ce que c'est de ces élections
européennes que va nître le nouveau
rapport de force à gauche en vue de
dessigner l'union de 2027 participera
bien sûr bien sûr mais je crois que il
faut quand
même se souvenir que l'objectif des
élections européennes c'est que
globalement toute la gauche fasse le
meilleur score possible et que on essaie
autant que possible d'éviter un
rassemblement national une extrême
droite en tout cas globalement qui
arrive en tête de ce scrutin on va voir
l'actualité dans nos région avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
au puit en Velet retrouver Christophe
Darne bonjour Christophe merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous rédacteur en chef de
l'éveil de la haute loi Christophe on va
parler avec vous d'une initiative de la
région auvern renal pour lutter contre
la désertification médicale c'est un
sujet qui se pose dans toute la France
et là la région va salarier des médecins
oui Orian parce que comme de nombreux
autres territoires et bien le
département de la hauteloire n'échappe
pas la problématique des déserts
médicaux c'est même une tendance qui
s'accélère ces dernières années avec des
généralistes qui partent en retraite et
qui ne sont pas remplacés des patients
qui se retrouvent sans médecins traitant
et même des secteurs entiers sans
soignant à moins de 45 minutes
alors face à cette situation et bien le
département de la hauteloire a décidé de
salarier des médecins dans les prochains
mois avec la volonté de devenir beaucoup
plus attractif l'idée c'est d'offrir
plus de souplesse à des professionnels
qui sont souvent de plus en plus
réticents face au libéral et ses
contraintes alors l'avantage de cette
formule pour eux ce sont des horaires
souples et des conditions plus
sécurisantes pour mener de front vie
professionnelle et vie personnelle en
2024 donc la hauteloire attend deux
généralistes et une secrétaire médical
euh qui devrait intervenir sur un
secteur en tension ce matin l'éveil de
la Haute Loire explique les contours de
ce dispositif qui s'explique qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre d'une grande
action qui comme vous le disiez a été
voulue par la région auverg ronalpe le
Jeep c'est son nom le groupement
d'intérêt public permet en fait
d'embaucher directement des médecins
alors concrètement la Région finance en
grande partie durant 2 ans les salaires
des médecins les collectivités locales
elles mettent à disposition l'ensemble
des nécessaire et ensuite si dispositif
est satisfaisant et bien les communes ou
communautés de communes pourrai prendre
le relais sur le plan financier alors ma
question Corine narassigin quel regard
d'abord portez-vous sur ce dispositif ce
dispositif et cette initiative et est-il
selon vous une des solutions pour mettre
fin au problèm des déserts médicaux en
France oui c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
la pour la Haute Loire et et je pense
que c'est une bonne chose que Laurent
vquz chois is de suivre l'exemple de
région dirigé par des socialistes
puisque c'est déjà le cas pour dans
centre Val de Loire avec François benau
et et et Carolle Delga en
Xitan je crois que les déserts médicaux
c'est un problème général dans tout le
pays à part quelques régions quelques
bordures même pas des régions hein des
quelques
bordures côtières on va dire on a on a
un problème de de déserts médicaux qu'on
soit en région plus en zone plus rural
ou en zone très urbaines comme en sa
Saint-Denis par exemple euh et donc
toutes les expérimentations toutes les
mesures qui sont mises en place par les
collectivités locales qui permettent euh
de traiter cette question de l'accès aux
soins qui est un droit fondamental euh
c'est une bonne chose euh et et mais je
crois que le législateur aussi doit
prendre ses responsabilités on doit
aussi évaluer je crois euh les
dispositifs divers et variés qui sont
mis en place par les collectivités
depuis plusieurs années maintenant dans
divers territoires pour regarder ce qui
marche le mieux euh pour essayer de bah
de regarder ce qui peut peut être
généralisable par la loi avec une
possibilité bien sûr d'adaptation selon
les besoins réels des territoires mais
juste prendre sa responsabilité ça veut
dire qu'il faut aller jusqu'à la
coerition oui c'est c'est le la position
du Parti socialiste depuis plusieurs
années c'est ce qui est aussi porté par
Guill gar à l'Assemblée nationale avec
un groupe transpartisan je dois le dire
même si malheureusement la majorité de
l'Assemblée nationale
donc majorité Renaissance les
républicains et la tot alité des députés
au rassemblement national ont voté
contre cela à l'Assemblée nationale mais
oui l'obligation d'installation ça doit
être un sujet qu'on on doit on doit
continuer à porter merci Christophe
Darne merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous regarde la Une de l'éveille de la
Hute Loire des médecins salariés face à
la pénurie c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous un mot sur votre région la la
région Île-de-France puisque il y aura
une nouvelle augmentation du Pass Navigo
au 1er janvier prochain qui passera
86,40 € par mois augmentation limitée à
l'inflation dit Valérie pecres qui
s'engage sur un bouclier tarifaire
jusqu'en 2031 est-ce que c'est une
victoire pour tous les Franciliens comme
elle le dit euh ça serait bien que Val
valéie PCR se préoccupe euh d'équilibrer
de gérer son budget de manière normale
euh et sans tomber à chaque fois dans
des psychodrame médiatique euh le le la
non augmentation du Pass Navigo c'était
un de ces des engagements de campagne
c'est la deuxième augmentation en 3 ans
et elle le fait alors que elle exige
déjà des augmentations de contributions
de tous les départements d'Île-de-
France et de la ville de Paris chaque
année pour le département de laass cette
année c'est 2,3 millions d'euros
supplémentaires de contribution à la
société de de transport gérée par la
région et donc là on voit bien qu'il y a
un problème beaucoup plus global et que
ça ne peut pas continuer comme ça elle
en est même à téléguider des amendements
on parla la loi l'immigration tout à
l'heure elle a tgué des amendements pour
quand même faire supprimer les
exonérations de de transport pour les
étrangers bénéficiaires de laame elle en
est là voilà donc là ça n'est vraiment
pas sérieux et en plus on aimerait quand
même que pour les Jeux Olympique qu'on
nutilise pas le prétexte des Jeux
Olympiques pourelle a annoncé des
augmentations voilà pour augmenter il aa
un pas spécial 16 € par jour 70 € par
semaine pour les gens qui n'ont pas de
Passe Navigo vous regrettez
oui parce que c'est c'est ça doit être
une grande fête et on doit accueillir
non seulement les les touristes qui vont
venir du monde entier mais aussi de
toute la France Les Français euh et donc
donc oui c'est c'est en plus ça rend les
jeux moins accessibles pour les les les
gens modestes qui n'ont pas les moyens
plus que on n'est pas sûr que la qualité
du transport va beaucoup s'améliorer et
donc oui c'est un problème et c'est donc
un problème plus global de sa de sa
gestion budgétaire merci corinaassigan
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première demi-heure dans